uh up next boys we have a little wed
better dead
this is way better we haven't done this
in forever hey brendan hey theo it's
diana from rhode island
i have a web better dead for you
wrestling style chyna
miss elizabeth or stephanie mcmahon so
let me know what you guys think
gang gang buzz buzz love the podcast
brendan get your ass to new england
because you never come to our area and
we would love to have you
love you guys don't touch me
but keep touching me
um okay have you been to new england
very you seem like a nice girl
oh thank you i have been in new england
brendan
oh well i'm not even trying to be
shooting here but dead would be china
right because
already dead i hate to be shitty about
it
she's already dead so that's kind of
cool now we're down to two
and stephanie mcmahon for god's sakes
daddy runs the company heavy on the man
legit billionaire uh
i would go yeah yeah
i agree lose the attitude you know chyna
also did pornography so she might be
doing
it you might want to bed her really
again
she passed you know yeah but we're
talking about living probably yes
oh if she were alive it's a tough one to
get by um
definitely not china cause i'm not into
dudes so there's
that okay that's kind of the big one
here's that meaty exterior
yeah you think she probably wears a
ralph lauren
polo remember when you stopped doing
steroids
she doubled down for life yeah dude
she's got those
those army legs god i would go probably
miss
elizabeth for sex
that's the best picture we got is she
from should she she was from the 80s
she's from 80s
yeah i've never heard of it oh yeah she
was one of like the uh like a promoter
kind of like she'll be a announcer she's
like a cheerleader
outside the ring not everybody she was
randy mcmahon wasn't she too with the
guy with the
mouth of the south yes elizabeth were
they together that was her he lift her
up
oh i'm definitely going uh stephanie
mcmahon
okay i would probably marry stephanie
man i do love with uh
i do love with elizabeth and i would
probably seat giant at the funeral
parlor you know and i would i would be
there for the funeral i'll get there
early yeah i'd go i'd go early check it
out
did you pick your who are you listen i'm
just i'm just marrying [ __ ] stuff and
big man the other two
could die i think well you have to pick
brendan because that's the thing okay
i'm uh marrying stephanie mcmahon and
then sex with the 80s
chick in the middle and then uh killing
the dude on the right
that's hilarious
[Music]
is